Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to ASTROCREEP
Now dig deep, DEEP, deep, deep back into the back recesses of your mind
where all the suppressed memories of your childhood lie lurking in the darkness.
Now if you remember way way back in the yonder year of twenty fifteen (2015)
You'll recall a game by the name of "The Visitor"
and The Visitor featured an incredibly curious alien that wanted to find out all about you,
but the only way he knew how was to
burrow deep, deep, deep into your BUTTHOLE!
Dig around a little bit,
and then just maybe a little bit take over your whole body and impersonate who you are and accumulate your DNA into its organic structure.
That's about the grossest intro that I've ever done, so I'm really proud of that.
You will also remember a game by the-FFFUUUUUCCCKK
I'm so pissed. That's better. That's what I wanted.
This is the quality Let's Play™ you guys have expected out of the Markiplier channel.
Ever had one of those days where everything goes wrong? Well this ain't one of those days,
that's my life!
Whatever it's not going to get any better
just like this let's play. I already know it's going downhill from the very get-go.
From time stamp 0:17. It started going downhill, trust me very much.
Anyway enough of that all that bullshit. We got Astrocreep here. Made by the same guy who made Cannibal Cafe.
And this one feature-and the reason why I brought up all this bullshit
Oh, "Two possibilities exist: Either we are alone in the universe or we are not. Both are equally terrifying."
But the reason I saw this-oooh. Use the mouse to click around the area
to find, guide the alien through doors. Your goal is to evolve to a stage that allows you to create a nest and
infest the entire space station.
You will need to kill the humans on board to evolve.
Different evolutionary forms unlock different options.
-Moan of Knowledge-
and this is where it all comes together, because in the preview for this game -
I saw an alien burrowing up someones butthole...
-Giggle of Childishness-
Boy howdy! Do I wanna get to that part of the game
So let's try to explore and meander
-Moan of Stupefaction-
Surprise surprise! I'm not dead!
Did someone literally just pick up this floating corpse in the middle of space and go like -
(Bad Impersonation) "Yeah sure!"
(Bad Impersonation) "I'll bring that on board my spaceship!
We've never even heard of the possibility of alien invaders and body snatchers!"
(Bad Impersonation) "That couldn't possibly happen."
So, we gotta go around here and try to find a way to get our little alien bu-
-Moan of Amazement-
-Moan of Disgust-
Oh! It's a birthing baby!
-Moan of Awe-
Listen to it's adorable squeal.. Of pain and -
-Moan of Concern-
It didn't like that! It's too hot for it centhshsitive body!
Oh that's better!
Dat definitely coo- Hey!
How is it going there friend ?
Do you want an alien inside of you?
There's some sex joke here and but I am not going to be able to -
AW!
Man, I did not know that that guy knew kung-fu.
Well.. Let's give that another go then shall we?
Okay, so we gotta incapacitate him first before we gonna be able to do what we need to do.
BLAM!
Blearghhh!
-More noises-
Good to know that thing's -
face was still intact so that I could bust my way through it.
Okay! So i can't immediately ding dong dead dang ditch this guy
So,
Either I go through vents which I cant
Cause I can't unlock it so I'll go through the door.
(To Oblivious Space Dude) "You'll never know!"
I am shadow in the night
A little disgusting slug like shadow in the night
Let's go to the rest room!
Because, If I remember something about burrowing inside someone's butthole (I did once)
It probably happens in the restroom
It's locked! Nevermind!
I'm-a gonna go away now!
Good thing they locked their bathrooms on these space stations.
"The Future Sure is Magical™"
Hello? Hi lady! You look very, very, very sad.
Hmkay, that's not gonna work.
That's not gonna work™
That's not gonna work™®
That's not gonna - None of this is gonna work
What the hell am I gonna -
♪ DO!? ♫
♫ What the hell am I gonna do!? ♪
Why are - Why isn't he curious
Why this thing opened and it's face exploded from within!
-Ghost have entered the space station-
(SP00KY) "It's a Ghoooooooost!"
"Drop your paaaaaaants!"
-A skeleton lives inside Mark-
-Moan of Discovery-
Aaahh! You had to click on the corners!
Okay!
So.. Uh.. I'm an idiot and I didn't even obviously click -
on the giant yellow things in front of my face,
but then again I never do.
So, not really need to worry about that
I'm.. I'm just incredibly stupid.
Okay! Right is right! I am gonna go right..
To the restroom maybe?
(Bad Impersonation) "Oh boy! It's a puzzle!
It's a puzzle!
Lets try this one on. It's lonesome
WoopI bet it's-Ohh no
Woop woop
Wee boop
OHHHH where do we go to now
Weee boop boop
Aww that didn't work at all
Wait a minute.
Something's not right about this
Okay boopity boopity boob
Then
Ahhh
and then
boop
(Gabe Newell) "No.."
Hey!
We did it!
Somehow?
I am very happy about that!
(Sarcasm) It wasn't random chance at all!
That was sc- OHHH it's time!
It's the moment we all have been waiting for.
I can't wait to cause this guy intestinal dd-
That's not what I meant to.. I didn't mean to
WOW! That guy got angry!
Well, I mean if a slug dropped on you, I guess you'd be angry
Don't tell me, I gotta go all the way back to the beginning
Okay good!
Thank You! You're nice!
-Beep-
Uh oh!
Ah!
AHH!
I was almost in there!
And that's not a good thing to say..
So I know what to do, it's the old "distraction method"
So..
HA BLIP
♪ And ♫
YES!
And then
UH OH
Shit's gonna go wrong for you! Quite literally.
-Man groaning in pain-
Hoooo-
ly -
SHIT!
I can now spit venomous barbs!
What was going on with that guy's DNA
That that is what I absorbed
I DO NOT wanna know
I don't need to know
I don't wanna go anywhere except away from this horrible, horrible mess that I have created
(Ace Ventura) "All righty then!"
(Bad Impersonation) "Let's go shall we!"
"Spit some poisonous barbs!"
-Moan of Revulsion-
Let's close that up, no one needs to know about my shame
Alright
♪ Goodbye! ♫
SCHRPEQUEUQ
Little skittery bitch
Alright
Now back in here to the.. (Contemplates existence)
I am sure he would've heard that noise
Okay how 'bout now?
(Bad Impersonation) "Heh! Right in the crotch!"
"That's what you get!"
"He's dead now."
Can I use his..
body
as DNA
Can I use "F. Thompson" 's body
Uh oh..
-Something eating something from a State Fair-
-Moan of Convulsion-
Could you stop that
Mmkay
Acidic evolution, vomit a highly corrosive acid that can melt
through all organic material and most metals
OR!
Telekinetic evolution -
Manipulate the will of organic organisms.
Move things with your mind.
Well that thee- theems bether
I am gonna go oooh It's a little head on legs..
Wha- Ohh why is he dancing?
He doesn't need to dance
It's a tiny baby head
on legs!
lerughh
bghh
Okay then!
I'manna skedaddle my way over here
Hey!
Do you wanna tekeneticalacaly manipulated?
Woooaaah
Oooo!
Hello!
My brain! My baby head is pulsating with telekinetic en- What are you doing?
What are you doing?
OHHHH
I had a sneaking suspicion that thi- that is a bouncy head
And far as I know that is a closed door over there
-Expresses contempt over situation-
I didn't need to do that!
I didn't need to kill her!
I could-a just clicked the card and go on through!
HEUGGGHHHHH
heeeeeuuuh
Heuuu- Okay, so I can't go through there because I don't have anything "acidic"
Which I guess is good..
HO! OHH OHH GOD
Oooohhh!
Your current ability is too weak to penetrate the lazer field.
You must evolve to a higher form
Oh really!
Good thing this guy is quick on the draw with that lazer field
and good thing there's a lazer field to begin with.
So I need to evolve to a higher form, huh?
Well good thing there's a convenient body-
right behind this door!
-Creepy alien music-
OH
NO! D:
OHHH
NOOO D:
That is Dead Space oh!
That is Dead Space™ oooh!
- Lots of no -
That is Dead Space straight up. that is one of the rare deaths
That is one of the rare deaths
That Isaac Clarke can go through in Dead Space. It's not often found.
You know that long gangly dude that falls apart into different things?
If that head strangles you and you die from that, it will literally rip your head off and then-
implant itself into your body.
It's one of the most horrific deaths in the game
And that was what was amazing about Dead Space
(Bad Alien Impersonation) "Hey! Buddy! It's me, Lauren!"
"Le- Let me through!"
"Look! It's me!
"Uh.. Your buddy!"
"HA HA!"
"It's your boo!"
"Maybe!"
Alright then ne- Woooooaaahh
-Tim Allen noise-
Okay
hah aw aw
haw haw
ohh
Pi- pick up this arm!
boobity boobity boop
Nothing weird about that!
boi deez deez..
ohh
Oh.. This sad sci- scientist didn't stand a chance against me
Oh I could-a just..
I could-a just-
gone right through the vents-
and none would bend the wiser.
Who would've known that would have the been pacifist route through this game.
OHH BOY
OHH DID I WIN?
DID I WON?
OHH BOY!
WOOOOOO
I dont feel like a winner,
but I guess I am!
Everyone's gonna die
and I'm gonna reign supreme on this parade.
Go me. Go me go
And speaking of going, where the hell are we going
AHH
IS THAT
OHH
Six hours later huh?
Is that when people start to get suspicious about the complete loss of crew on this ship?
ERRR I don't wanna know what happened in theeeerree!
HE HE HE HE HE HEEE
HEEEE
- VOMIT -
I don't wanna know
I don't wanna know how I was "infestinating" that thing by myself.
Okay
I'm gonna go the other route
So I'll be right back once I get to the jjjjj-unction.
I was about to say juxtaposition, but that's the wrong word for this situation.
Eat this!
HAHA!
What a loser
got killed by an alien
and now we're gonna be like all acidic and shit
gggeerh
weeffbefbejg
I'm so..
I'm so angry!
- Giggles like the manchild he is-
Look at the way drags his tentacles across-
That's adorable
-Gurbles like a BYEAH-
No one suspects a thing!
I'm sure that she doesn't want to mess with me.
-Alien language-
This is the pacifist route
oh boy!
no no! -vomit-
I'm sorry! Excuse me, that was very rude of me
plus all the murder that I'm not doing. ;)
Oh no! I do have to murder him
oh no
He won't know what's gonna happen!
Ooohh you're
ahhhh!
Man! This poor guy! No matter what happens to him, he just gets disintegrated.
Can I still use- ?
-Mark turns into a zombie-
I don't want that!
NO
oh no..
oh noo
So what happens when I go back and see the lady?
Is she gonna freak out because now I'm-
Ooh it's back up.
Dangit! That was my opportunity go through there.
ohh noo
ahhhh
Nahh I don't think there was an arrow there anyway.
So I couldn't have gone back that's why I went left first anyway.
So that wasn't even an option
So I shouldn't be too worried about that
(Bad Alien Impersonation) "Don't mind me!"
"Jsh-ust sh-tomping my way to victory!"
-Alien language-
"Ah yesh, yesh!"
"Thish looksh like an excellent closet to mashturbate furioushly-"
-For shix shtraight hoursh!"
"And then.."
"My goal hash been accomplished!"
"The entire world ish infeshted!"
"Oh oh! Good thing I got a lower body"
"Caushe that wash all that I needed!"
Okay!
So we are done
We are all done here
woo boy!
That was horrifying
But either way that is: ASTROCREEP.
and oddly enough alot of fun!
like that morbid curiousity little bit for this type of game
Is kinda fun to see.
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you in the next video.
-Markiplier waves off to his non-existent friends- <3